MD is starting to round out its rx 5000
series of GPUs having started at the
middle and planning to work its way
outward the newest addition to Andy's
family of GPUs is the RX 5500 xt
following the previously announced om
model our 6500 not XD and DIY available
5700 XT and 5700 cards the 5500 xt has
four gigabyte and eight gigabyte options
available with MSRP at 160 and 200
dollars respectively putting it in most
direct competition with the 1650 super
at 160 well test three models of 5500 XT
today including thermals we BIOS
programming gaming performance vram
differences in capacity and noise before
that this video is brought to you by the
Thermaltake core p3 the core p3 is one
of the most versatile cases on the
market it includes a wall mounting
hardware if a showcase is what you're
after
but it can also run as a standing or
horizontal test bench making it highly
accessible for modifying and
overclocking Hardware the case includes
tempered glass and an open-air layout
for easy management and high visibility
offering a truly unique chassis for
enthusiasts learn more at the link in
the description below so first of all
let me apologize I'm extremely sick
right now it happened right in the
beginning of this review cycle but I
apologize if I'm a bit nasally in this
review I do my best we have a lot of
data to go through though the 5500 xt
card still runs on the same Navi
architecture it still use a seven
nanometer manufacturing process but it
cuts down some other features the die
size obviously is one of the areas where
cost savings come out because it's 158
millimeters squared versus the original
57 rx TDI of 251 millimeters squared and
that reduces manufacturing cost
significantly it improves the yield
which also reduces manufacturing cost
significantly because you're throwing
away fewer dies for Less silicon for the
product and ultimately the result is
increased yield for a smaller die other
than that notable differences include a
reduction to 22 compute units each
containing the usual 64 stream
processors you multiply it out compute
units time stream process or x 64 gives
you total stream processor count the
for comparison had 40 compute units and
AM D is still sticking with its
painfully bad name in convention here
for the clock says game clock and boost
clock with game clock presumably going
with its game cache which is honestly
probably one of the worst decisions Andy
has ever made for anything relating to
product marketing because that was for
rise on 3000 launched which didn't need
marketing help they didn't need to do to
the we're trying to relate to gamers by
renaming something that's been in
existence for decades as something else
with the word game in it anyway well
cash has been in existence for decades
anyway l3 is a bit more reason but l3
was renamed game cache but the game
clock thing let's just redefine back to
what people are used to this is not news
this has been around since na'vi came
out but when AMD says game clock what
they mean is the traditional
interpretation of boost clock and when
they say boost clock what they mean is
peak opportunistic boost which can
happen for as little as one millisecond
so basically the the boost clock we can
ignore both these numbers because we're
with partner models today that have
potentially done some tuning and v bios
will talk about all that as we go
through the review and a couple of other
things to talk about before we really
get into stuff the cards that it's rated
for 130 watt for board power budget and
the cards can of course tweak their
power budget afforded to the GPU by the
bios and that's done based on the board
partner and if they have a good enough
drm to accompany it so we'll talk about
the power budget of the power color red
dragon were reviewing and of the
sapphire pulse for reviewing then we
also have eight and four gigabyte models
of the pulse to look at as well and
finally a note on overclocking we're
going to show some results in the charts
for the 4 gigabyte sapphire pulse that
are bad and the reason we've included
those is because they are overclocked
results but with overclocking
specifically on am the in general you
should do this but specifically on AMD
you really need to validate your results
as you increase the clocks because what
will happen is it'll look like you have
a much higher stable clock than you
actually do
because the bigger numbers will
why and they all potentially hold it
might not crash you might not get the
black screens and catastrophic failures
you get with Nvidia but actually you
kind of would prefer to have those
failures because it tells you hey this
stuff's not working
whereas with these cards typically what
will happen is you push and push and
push and you end up with an unstable
setting now with a 5500 XT four gigabyte
model we spent about half a day about
six hours on it overclocking it and
we're never able to get it to improve
beyond stock by any measure that was
worth mentioning at all it was typically
one to two FPS maximum Delta not even
positive just different from the stock
results and then we included some of the
results where it's bad when overclocked
specifically to illustrate why you need
to validate your results and not just
tell everyone on the internet what you
set and how great it is because it might
not actually be working anyway that's
just a note for you let's get into the
testing data we've got all the games
thermals and more and then we'll talk
conclusions before we do any comparisons
between the eight gigabyte and four
gigabyte models later we need to make
sure they're running at roughly the same
frequency as any differences here would
potentially invalidate testing that
attempts to isolate memory capacity
during standardized frequency testing
and a reproduced frame of firestrike
extreme we measured the eight gigabyte
sapphire rx 5500 XT pulse at about 1835
to 18 40 megahertz average with peaks at
about 18 50 megahertz the four gigabyte
model averaged slightly higher around
1840 to 1845 megahertz and peaked at
about eighteen fifty six megahertz given
that our difference between these two is
typically about five to seven megahertz
point-to-point we're close enough that
these are basically identical we're more
on the lookout for numbers closer to 15
the 25 megahertz are greater five to
seven megahertz gap won't meaningfully
contribute to performance differences
and so these two can be fairly compared
and head-to-head tests as an attempt to
isolate from memory differences without
needing to do any tweaking into the core
clock which is good because AMD's
drivers are still terrible to work with
for any kind of frequency changes we
intentionally zooms this scale to 1800
to 1900 megahertz so that the difference
is easier to see
and extremely exaggerated so keep in
mind that we have blown out the scale of
this intentionally although we typically
like to start at zero let's get into
some thermal tests we have a lot of
these but we'll start with the
comparative between power color and
Sapphire for their 8-gigabyte models
just because this is typically what
differentiates one card from the next
it's not actual gaming performance those
are all going to be about the same for
framerate and you'll see that today but
it's more about the quality of life
differences and the noise at a given
temperature for the red dragon versus
the Sapphire 5500 xD poles with the
pulse set to it's 130 watt default V
bios called OCB bios and the red dragon
sent to it's only 130 watt v bios so
we're normalized for power which is
important as well the two cards plot as
follows the power color red dragon at 40
DBA plots the GPU edge temperature of
about 57 degrees Celsius with the pulse
is 40 DBA edge temperature at about 59
degrees for the target at 40 DBA this
has more to do with how the V bios is
set their fan thermal response more than
anything else but because we've
eliminated the fan part of that we were
able to better see how the thermal
response is if you're just running stock
all you're really looking at is what
number did they set the temperature
target to you're not really testing much
else Junction temperature matters much
more though and we see the pulse at
about 76 degrees Celsius versus the 80
degrees Celsius of the red dragon this
is outside of error or variance but also
is not a tremendous difference thus far
the pulse is faring better at the same
noise levels as far as GD dr6 thermals
we'll just throw that on the screen
really quickly they're basically the
same between the two cards there's no
difference this doesn't affect the
decision-making at all this chart shows
the fan thermal response on their full
stock conditions both the pulse and the
red dragon run extremely low fan speeds
averaging about 32 to 34 DBA at our
standard 20 inch distance when under
stock settings which is really quiet and
low speed this is the advantage of two
comparatively good coolers when matched
with a relatively low power consumption
GPU the pulse on the red dragon we're
good with the 57 100x tees there's the
709 Ike T is and they're both good
the 5500 XTS as well and that just
scales even better when the GPU doesn't
consume as much powers the previous
model so the pole spins up to about
1,100 rpm and to maintain a 70 degree
edge temperature with the red dragon
spending at 1300 RPM its maintain about
a 63 to 65 degree edge temperature both
are below 34 DBA for the GPU core power
budget pre-configured for each cards via
BIOS the Sapphire pulls silently bias
targets 120 watts shown on this charge I
mean at a reduction to better control
for noise by reducing fan speeds with
that extra thermal allowance from
reduced power
meanwhile the OCB bios runs about 130 to
135 watts and the power color red dragon
v bios does about 130 watts fixed we're
getting into games now we'll start with
our usual of Sniper Elite 4 which we
like because it's so consistent and
predictable it's allowed us to build up
a mountain of data for this particular
game because it doesn't really change
much we'll move to more modern games
after this and then add a couple of dx11
games at the end for some type relate
for at 1080p the RX 5,500 xt 8 gigabyte
GPUs both the power color and sapphire
versions of these cards end up at about
101 to 102 FPS average the 4 gigabyte
pulse lands at 102 to 103 FPS average
which is well within test variants and
equivalent to the 8 gigabyte models
there's no difference between them
you cannot state there's a difference
it's all within error frame time
consistency as illustrated by one
percent in point one percent lows though
we'll have frame time plots for this and
other games later are also equal between
the two cards there's no difference you
should just buy the 4 gigabyte model and
not waste money on the 8 gigabyte model
in this scenario the 1650 super
meanwhile is outperforming marginally by
the 5500 XT when both are stock at 100
FPS average versus 101 to 102 FPS
average this difference is definitely
not noticeable and frame time pacing is
also equivalent between them
overclocking the 1650 super got it - 105
FPS average and overclocked in the 5500
XT cards got them to 107 to 108 FPS
average and in this game the overclocked
held a bit better than the others to the
500 XT 4 gigabyte model shadow of the
Tomb Raider is next on the list
using direct x12 and tested at both
1080p and 1440p at 1080p vr x 6500 xt 8
gigabyte pulse ran at about 70 FPS
average with lows at 61 fps 1% and 59
FPS 0.1% compared to the 5500 xt is 4
gigabyte 63 FPS average we actually did
see meaningful uplift in this title to
the tune of about 11% overclocking the
5500 xt 4 gigabyte was a frustrating
waste of time in general but in this
title we see part of the reason why in a
best-case scenario it did nothing while
the more typical worst-case scenario was
performance degradation because of
instability as for whether the 8
gigabyte model would be worse than over
the 4 gigabyte model the average FPS
uplift is less important at this price
in Delta than the frame time Delta where
we see frames have inconsistency plummet
with the 4 gigabyte 5500 XD that said
despite a meaningful uplift at a $200
price target for 8 gigabytes versus the
16 for these super 4 gigabytes 160
availability for equivalent performance
we'd have to give overall victory to the
1650 super in this benchmark note
further that we as you'll see later did
not really see this 4 vs. 8 gigabyte
disparity in almost any other title it's
mostly exclusive to tomb raider and
otherwise the difference is more clock
bound on the core or core resource bound
not memory capacity bound and videos
memory compression maybe giving it an
edge here the 5500 XT doesn't offer
meaningful frame time performance uplift
either and is nearing the wider error
margins for frame time measurements at
these naturally lower sample count
metrics when compared to the 1650 super
overclocked in the 1650 super puts it at
75 FPS average while overclocking the
myth if I wanted XD 8 gigabyte what is
that 74 FPS average the two are the same
we need more data from other games
before joining firm conclusions here as
to who's doing best but we'll look at
some frame time data first and just
before that power color since the 500 xt
8 gigabyte red dragon also did about 70
FPS average stock performing
equivalently in all ways to the 5500 XD
8 gigabyte pulse for this frame time
plot we'll be comparing the 5500 XD 4
gigabyte
eight gigabyte and six teams with these
supermodels to each other at 1080p this
is the best run of four from each device
the RF 6500 xt8 gigabyte is fairly
consistent from start to finish with
frame times ranging from clusters around
12 to 14 milliseconds at the start of
the test to 15 milliseconds in the
middle and approaching 16 milliseconds
at the end remember lower frame times
are better and more consistent frame
times are best the plot shows
performance frame to frame and is the
best illustration possible of the base
metric of performance which is time
rather than the abstraction that FPS is
the 5500 XD for gigabyte model
encounters a couple of large frame time
spikes visible to the user as stutters
or hitches the worst is an excursion to
about 34 milliseconds for a single frame
first of the previous frames time of
about 18 milliseconds this happens again
to a lesser degree later and seems to be
mostly exclusive to our shadow of the
Tomb Raider tests whereas the 4 gigabyte
and 8 gigabyte models showed no
meaningful difference elsewhere we'd
assume Nvidia's memory compression and
comparatively reduced architectural
dependency on bandwidth leads to this
Delta but we were able to reproduce the
results on the 4k right model the 1650
super meanwhile mostly matches the 5500
xt 8 gigabyte card and can be seen as
functionally the same in performance
there is no perceptible difference
between these two in this benchmark at
1440p the 5500 ex tak white pulse lands
at 47 FPS average not bad considering
this isn't really the target resolution
for the card and the 5500 XD 4 gigabyte
model does about 44 FPS the 5500 xt 4
gigabyte OC hinders performance as a
result of poor stability and frankly for
overclocking software and so it advise
against wasting your time in most
instances the 1650 Superstock GB Ron's
48 6.5 FPS average with loes
functionally equivalent with the 5500 XD
8 gigabyte overclocking the 8 gigabyte
5500 XT and the 1650 super ty them at
about 50 FPS average the power color red
dragon 5500 xt 8 gigabyte ended up at 47
FPS average again the same as the
sapphire pulse when both are stocked
strange brigade is next we originally
introduced this benchmark for Vulcan
versus DirectX 12 comparison
but after finding they were nearly
identical in most instances we've moved
away from the volcan testing to just
dx12 you can watch some of our initial
tests from the 5700 XT or the 27 the 20
series refresh is for more detail on
this if you're curious the 5,500 xt 8
gigabyte model for the sapphire poles
and the 5,500 xt 4 gigabyte model were
identical and within test variants in
this benchmark and at least this test
there is no value added from the extra
$40 spent on the 8 gigabyte model the
power color 5500 XT and sapphire 5500 xt
8 gigabyte models both run at about 65
FPS average and so are the same thermals
and noise are more of a differentiator
than our high performance here as always
has been the case of the partner models
for the 5000 series so far overclocking
gains us at nearly nothing with 2 to 3
FPS being the best we saw while
maintaining stability with AMD is frail
overclocking support and its drivers the
4 gigabyte model again proved a waste of
time to overclock given its performance
regression on frame times as for the
1650s super the stock card runs 62 FPS
average with the overclocked also not
worthwhile on this title at 64 FPS
average although at least it works
predictably the 1650 super allows the
5500 XD for gigabyte stock card a lead
of about 4.6 percent this isn't
particularly perceptible in this title
but is a noteworthy gain for the same
priced 4 gigabyte 5500 XT that puts it
in an advantageous position I guess the
1650 super hitman 2 is another DirectX
12 title that we can look at that's
relatively recent for this one at 1080p
the RX 5500 xt 4 gigabyte and 8 gigabyte
models both run at about 72 FPS average
with low as unchanged between them this
puts the knight roughly rx 590 Fatboy
levels of performance and a bit ahead of
the rx 588 gigabyte card previously the
5500 XT overclocked the successful of
the two noting that we left the failure
on here for illustration runs at 76 FPS
average or an uplift of about 4.8% over
stock the 1650 super runs natively at
seventy six point eight FPS average in
this title with lows about the same as
the 5500 XT cards at overclocking
to get 282 FPS average at 1440p the RX
5500 xt 4 gigabyte ends up at 49 FPS
average 0.1% Louis as always are a
complete mess in this title for DX 12 so
we remove them the 5500 xt 8 gigabyte
model does fit the FPS average 1 stock
on the red dragon or about the same with
the pulse there's no meaningful
difference between the 8 gigabyte and 4
gigabyte 5500 XC cards even at 1440p
where they're strained a lot more so
once again you shouldn't waste your
money on the more expensive of the two
at least for this game the gtx 1650
super manages 52 FPS average allowing it
to outperform the stock to do 500 XD
cards in an overall imperceptible but
measurable way overclocking places at 54
FPS average allowing the 1660 Superstock
card still a lead of 13% in this title 4
points of reference the RX at the 700
red dragon runs at 77 FPS average here
allowing it a lead over the 5500 xt 4 or
8 gigabyte models by about 52% the price
jump obviously is also large but that
extra performance glass puts you in more
1440p or even 4k ready scenarios moving
now from the newer titles to the oldest
title just for a balance with some dx11
benchmarking we see GTA 5 at 1080p has
the RX 5500 XD 4 gigabyte and 8 gigabyte
models including both power color and
sapphire all roughly equivalent at 83 to
84 FPS average we're within test
variants those are also roughly equal at
a reliable 55 FPS 30.1% these 1650 super
finds itself in the same cluster albeit
with slightly lower 0.1% frame time
consistency at 45 FPS rather than 55 FPS
for this title if judging strictly
between the 4 gigabyte an 8 gigabyte
5500 xt cards there's no value added by
spending the extra money on the aka by
model as for overclocking the 5500 xt 8
gigabyte ends up at 87 FPS average and
overclocked whereas these 1650 super
ends up at about 89 FPS average at 1440p
the 5500 xt and 1650 super alike proved
relatively capable of playing this older
game
with our higher graphics configuration
if you wanted to play older games like
GTA 5 at 1440p it's completely doable on
these modern $160 video cards the 5500
XT 4 gigabyte and a gigabyte cards are
roughly equivalent again and just in
case you really didn't want to play
games like this dropping anti-aliasing
for example down to 0 would allow you to
get over 60fps and a title like this one
so 50 of our water XT is doing
reasonably here but for an 8 gigabyte do
not prove any different in this one
another slightly older title on our
bench is f1 2018 using DirectX 11 and
generally playable settings on most
Hardware at 1080p VR 6500 XD a gigabyte
model by power color and by sapphire
both do about 79 to 80 FPS average with
the 4 gigabyte model nearly identical in
every measure of performance there's not
only no meaningful difference between
these two memory capacities but also no
measurable one you'd be better off
skipping the eight gigabytes q it
doesn't make sense at the price and
provides no value in this game
as for the 1650 super its performance
runs slightly higher in averages at 83
although Nvidia cards have always had an
issue in our testing with f1 2018 we're
their frame time consistency is spotty
for 0.1% lows in this title exposing a
disadvantage in this particular bench at
1440p the RX 6500 XT for gigabyte model
ended up at 62 FPS average with the 8
gigabyte option at 0.1 FPS different
that's test variants once again and lows
are also within variants the two are the
same
the 1650 Super is slightly outperforms
both at 63 FPS average although the
Delta is not perceptible to any human
player power colours 5500 xt 8 gig white
falls within the same performance range
with an overclock on the 5500 xt 8
gigabyte offering a couple of percentage
points increase and an overclock on the
sixteen to these super pushing it just
past the 5500 xt 8 gigabyte OC
overall these cards are all roughly the
same and don't offer a meaningful
difference in feel of the game the 4
gigabyte overclock again proved to be
fruitless and dropping it further only
produced similar issues or a complete
lack of uplift so
even with lower results it just did or
lower-frequency targets it just didn't
matter
so really recap things quickly here we
think you should mostly skip the eight
gigabyte model and if considering the
5500 XC at all you can probably just
focus on the four gigabyte model it's
cheaper buy a lot actually at this price
range that's a significant percentage of
the total cost and it's also
functionally the same performance and
nearly everything we tested now there
are probably going to be games we did
run into one of them but they're
probably going to be games where it
matters a bit more at 1080p though on
average you're not typically going to be
running into the vram limitation when
you're talking about four gigabytes as
your minimum so we really think you
should mostly skip the eight gigabyte
model kind of like when the RX 570
launched if you don't recall we
recommended everyone skip the the 8
gigabyte model there and go for four
because it got you basically all the
performance you can even overclocking
get pretty damn close to a stock 580 so
same situation here where the 4 gigabyte
model compared to the 8 gigabyte model
is extremely good it's $40 cheaper and
if anything Andy launching two versions
of this has made their cheaper option
look significantly better by providing a
relative comparison with the 60 with the
$40 more expensive option from 160 to
200 that has mostly the same performance
but technically not always but it's
really damn close so that's how that
pans out the 1660 super would probably
be the next worthwhile step up if you
want to spend a bit more money and get
more guaranteed 1440p playable
performance and pretty much every game
then the 1660 super would be our
recommendation for you it's not a
massive jump from a $200 50 500 XD it
provides a meaningful performance uplift
it gets you into another class of
resolution if you want to spend less you
should be looking at the 1650 super or
the 5500 XT for gigabyte both at $160
and there are cheaper cards but it's not
not really particularly worth stepping
down in there you might want to consider
use if you're trying to spend less than
160 bucks right now
performance is overall okay the 5500 XC
is kind of a mess
it's not something we're really mad
about at all and it's not something
we're really excited about it's just
fine and that's kind of what you expect
in this price class that's not a bad
thing it just means that doesn't really
rock the boat a whole lot you get 1650
super performance from an alternative
from a competitor and you pick between
the two based on other features or if
you have some strange bad allegiance to
a company which you shouldn't have and
you should cast that away but that's
really the main thing here is you get an
alternative and they're about the same
performance now the problem we have with
AMD for this card Andy has done a lot
they've put a whole lot of makeup on
their driver and it looks great visually
they've done a lot of things to make it
look like the new dynamic web 3.0 or
whatever style of driver package which
is partly cool except for the head
really annoying sound effect it makes
but it's it's good to see and I am the -
its credit does and has had some of the
best options and its drivers for a while
Nvidia for example deserves a whole lot
of I don't know what we'll call it scorn
for killing shadow play and its
usefulness by requiring and mandating
that you log into GeForce experience
with an account
AMD really makes up for it with relive
where relive works great and it has
fewer requirements in that regard
less telemetry the problems I have with
this two years or more now AMD has been
unable to fix its fan profiling I've
been complaining about it since Vega
frontier Edition and I'm sorry if this
is old for you but it's still going on
and AMD damnit you need to fix it if you
have a feature in your drivers it needs
to work if it's not going to work don't
put it in there don't make me think that
the things in your drivers will always
work because then I'm going to spend six
hours trying to make them work but
actually it never will it's not possible
in some instances whether this is a
problem with the board partners
conforming to your API or a problem with
your API and software itself
is irrelevant the problem is that the
fan profiling still doesn't work at
least half of the time if not more
across all of the 5000 series models
we've tested and your board partners
blame you AMD and I'm sure a.m. that you
will blame the board partners and sharam
these fans will defend it for some
inexplicable reason despite the fact
that we've said Andy has a lot of good
products right now it also has a lot of
things that needs to keep fixing so the
problems mostly stem from overclocking
the overclocking feature set and Andy's
drivers is still partially broken we
could probably just do a whole
livestream demonstrating how it's broken
to save everyone the time fan profiling
the fan still gets stuck at the higher
fan RPMs when you set them you have to
reboot or wait upwards of about 10
minutes to get it to restore back to
where it was so if we set for example a
fan rpm of 80% and we run a test and we
want to set the next one to 50% because
maybe 80 percents too loud we don't like
it anymore
you basically have to reboot or just
walk away from the computer and come
back 10 plus minutes later and maybe
they'll return to where you've said it
so working up is fine if you go from 50
to 80 it responds instantly if you were
from 80 to 50 it doesn't respond at all
in a lot of instances so is it's some
weird software issue but that said I'm
I'm going to have to again reiterate
that the hardware is actually fine and
it's very competitive with the 16 to the
super it's a fair alternative if you
prefer to buy it absolutely go ahead
you're not really losing a whole lot and
in some instances you gain a bit so the
card the GPU is fine we don't mind it
I'm sure the Andy people the fans can
freak out in the comments about I mean
again not liking the drivers but frankly
they're a problem and if you really like
AMD that much you should also want them
to fix it because then I'll stop
complaining about it every review we do
and you know also one more thing
sometimes in software like gpu-z or
other third-party software which is
typically extremely reliable you'll see
the fan speed percentage reported as
over a hundred percent it's actually not
possible for the fans to be overclocked
so
what that really means is that it's off
by about 20% we found the offset so the
fan rpm will be accurately read i
double-checked it with a physical
tachometer but the percentage reported
will be wrong so am the drivers will
report like 40 for example ji pzr stuff
might report 56 or 60 something and
that's just something you need to be
aware of doesn't really affect
functionality just I don't know it just
trusts the RPM number not the percentage
it's all I can give you there anyway
cards fine
software still needs improvement despite
and these massive fanfare about their
new version please aim the let's make
everyone's job easier here thanks for
watching subscribe for more go to stored
on cameras axis down at the hubs out
directly or patreon.com/scishow and axis
I'll see you all next time
[Music]